what to you is the most beautiful idea
in physics chemistry or mathematics whoo
let's go to that place first before we
go to the to Kiev the most beautiful in
physics chemistry I would say I would
say Einstein his ideas regarding
stochastic motion and Brownian motion I
think it is the most beautiful clear
simple idea because from this like
statistics you can prove existence of
molecules believe me or not it was I
think it was his first publication in
1905 with his first wife actually it was
significantly her idea that's right they
were collaborators yes those five four
four five papers he published yeah
actually almost everything which
Einstein did it was published of the
most important stuff he published in one
here one nine on five but the first idea
was probably the most elegant cases
large Brownian motion and why you think
it's beautiful you see that people at
that time they understand that if
molecules if they exist their motion is
absolutely chaotic
boom-boom-boom-boom-boom what he proved
the dust matter what size of particles
is there motionless similar about the
same so it is not necessary to see
molecules you can look at bigger
particles like if you smoke there is
particles and you can see like a
propagation of this smoke and from here
determine behavior of molecules and
that's actually relatively short very
elegant very clear and at that point
people they kept talking about molecules
but it was no proof because there is no
like a super electronic microscope to
see them so you know I'm saying yes
molecules exist you said well
I mean can you show me there so Einstein
made it and book and he proved that a
lot of people after this public hearing
said hmm probably molecules really
exists
Einstein in 1905 so what do you like
about that idea the isn't olicity
simplicity the solicitor's we proving
something it's very very very very very
very complicated so if I ask you for
example you know molecules like this can
you prove it
obviously like now you would say okay I
have a special electronic microscope and
I can we'll take a look that small okay
but when you go back to beginning of
20th century people they were laughing
can you prove something you know you can
no no no no take a look it's something
very simple very very simple very very
simple what do you think it takes to do
that kind of thinking and come to those
ideas and how many times have you
encountered those kinds of ideas in your
life have you had any yeah yeah I would
say that's a that's a whole beauty my
feeling that's a whole beauty of science
it's just you know people they say no no
no no it's so - it's impossible or and
you say no no wait take a look take a
look wait a second did they take a look
just think for five minutes if something
is very complicated you know kapitza
Nobel Prize alright like I work with him
by the way he used to say if it is
complicated it's probably wrong ah well
it was a lot of discussion didn't
kapitza england ow because landau he he
enjoyed to do something in a most
complicated way why his friend kapitsa
he was trying to do everything is an
absolutely simple way and they had all
these discussions because sometimes
capital he went to extremes
and he used to say well this is simple
it means this is right now he was like
okay you means that everything we simple
is right I mean like Fineman - Wow yeah
you like the simple yes yes yes yes
that's the whole point to find this
simplicity that's that's the beauty of
science that's a beauty really there's a
beautiful that's something worse to do
like at the risk of going religious for
a second why do you think our universe
allows for such simplicity to be
discovered that such simplicity exists
at all I can I can tell you it is very
similar to Darwin's theory why I don't
know why animals they're this way not
the other way so it is actually
competition take a look about simplicity
in beauty of physics like you have two
interacting planets and the force is
proportional to one over R squared in
this case they are able to go in circles
or ellipses if there is another law they
are either falling or we're out so like
so if like our solar system exists so
just the interactions would be at 1 over
R squared that's it it's very
interesting about Isaac Newton and his
way of thinking that's also was the
super I would say genius
you